my name is chalice McDonough and I'm the
senior regional spokeswoman for the
World Food Programme for East Africa the
people of South Sudan fought a war for
independence from Sudan for decade and
three years ago through a referendum and
a transition process they voted she
become a separation she actually became
the country of South Sudan the coalition
of factions and groups within South
Sudan that have united in order to make
that independent country but basically
is fractured when the conflict broke out
in December it all happened very quickly
and we saw an enormous displacement in
the civilian population and then
graduate a conflict spread over the
coming days and week and basically
blossomed into a full-scale civil war
people were unable to plant their crops
journeyman rental plantings he didn't
and that means that they're not going to
have a harvest when the rainy season
ends we're very worried about the effect
that that is going to have on some
security in the coming months and the
country is in a rainy season 60% of the
roads of the country is not accessible
by Road so the only way to reach them is
by air and there's no way to even land a
plane so we just have to actually drop
the food out of the plane and then have
people on the ground to collect it and
we're very concerned that if the
fighting doesn't stop that the
conditions could really get much more
quickly so it's going to take sustained
humanitarian interventions over the next
six months to make sure that these areas
don't slide into the famine
you